[Applause]  [Applause]  vacations will be so amazing  [Music]  [Music]  Julie Marie Richard are you be my wife  you two should be tasted science we've  been around awhile  so we can help we would love to I know  somewhere by the for must we go where  will blow your mind  incredible razor Space Ghost hath  graveyard attorneys are too scared to  destroy him smell the ghost answers end  up here I'm gonna have a look here  you should take her it's over there for  your journey  Hey  a long time ago there was a woman she uh  she died on a good death wanna add  people entire we call her my thumbnail  if you disturb the dwarfs house she will  come for you  you